yo man bootleg head podcast
we got the homie from the bay area yes
sir who has very polarizing hip-hop
opinions
homie simba is here what's happening
with you brother what's up man
feeling great thank you for having me
man i'm a big fan of this show i love
the freddie gibbs
rick gibbs episode yeah that episode got
sloppy
we drank a whole bottle in 1942 and it
was entertaining and [ __ ]
yeah uh shout out to freddie man cause
he don't got no filter anyway and then
when he's drunk it's
uh there was a lot taken out of that
interview we had to take some [ __ ] out
of there i think freddie you might have
started some wars with that interview
freddy might have is i'm going back and
forth with three of them but he might
have album of the year
dude me and you see things are the same
way okay
alfredo to me is album of the year what
you what's your three that you're going
back and forth with
see benny just kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] up okay
cause i had i had alfredo
um i had
[Music]
what was the [ __ ] album i was
listening i can't even think off the top
right now but i had alfredo
i had nas in there i had
um
i had big sean in there
and it was one more that i can't think
right now at the top of my head but i
had those three for sure but benny
album is like yeah that's dope i did a
list
i did a list uh earlier in the year
before a lot of like big sean and nas
dropped and i had
alfredo's one
and then somewhere in there there was
like pray for parish from west side gun
yeah i think run the drills fours though
running jewels was definitely dope but
since then
i mean little baby my turn is not an
album that i
necessarily but you got to give him his
respect
that was mine that's the one you got to
put that up
it was baby because for me i've been
listening to little baby since he first
came out right
so to hear the growth yeah you hear the
growth and just not only his tone and
voice but just his lyrics and beat
selection and the way he's jumping in
and out of cadences and
his subject matter for sure i think uh
yeah i think big sean detroit too
uh is up there for me i just felt like
it was a super vulnerable album
definitely conway [ __ ] it was that time
too for some news
any [ __ ] it's been a great year for
hip-hop but i think that
alfredo is still number one i'm with you
man i'm with you i'm nice not too far
off i'm with you